Jimmy after last game one day you saw
some doubles and you're able to make
plays off those doubles tonight did you
when did you get the sense that they
weren't going to send as much help and
did you see it as an opportunity to
create more shots for yourself yes uh I
was trying to play the right way the
entire game
and then I feel like in the fourth it's
all about getting a bucket whether
you're taking a contested shot a wide
open shot it's all about getting shots
on goal and I can only tell y'all so
many times how much confidence that my
teammates put in me the coaching staff
put to me to just go out there and hoop
play carefree and um as we like to say
in our locker room take us there
Jimmy before you got up here we've been
talking about Grant Williams and what
happened there in the fourth quarter and
Bam even suggested that you occasionally
start things like that to just kind of
get yourself going can you tell us what
happened in the moment there and did it
fuel you down the stretch
yes it did but that's just competition
at his finest um he hit a big shot
um
started talking to me I like that I'm
all for that
um it makes me
um key in a lot more and it it pushes
that will that I have to win a lot more
and um it makes me smile it does when
people talk to me I'm like okay I know
I'm I'm a decent player if you want to
talk to me out of everybody that you can
talk to but um I don't know it's just
it's just competition I I do respect him
though he he's a big part of what they
try to do he switches he can shoot the
ball
um I just don't know if um
I'm the best person to talk to
so Jimmy Grant wasn't the answer was he
did you know about the problem
[Music]
he wasn't
that's what that the end of that post
game was about that's what you're
referencing that's not what it's about
[Music]
um
but I don't know I think so many guys
play well for us tonight you know Caleb
was was huge as was bam
um and I just think we played high
energy and everybody's going to focus in
on that but that's for sure not the
reason why we won the game
I think what Caleb did tonight was
incredible in keeping us in the game
um you you can't leave him he's on
everybody's account report he does
everything that you ask him to do and
then band was bam rebounding
um passing the ball scoring the ball
and then um I made some shots late
that's the ball game one last one can
you tell us about the song you're
listening to on the way in here uh
Morgan Wallen
um somebody's problem it's uh
it's a hit in the locker room right now
but honestly speaking I think I'm kind
of like the the DJ so I get to pick and
choose what we listen to if it's not him
it's Dermot Kennedy uh it might be some
gospel in there who knows
Jimmy fourth quarter execution both here
in game two and also in in game one they
seem to be very much out of rhythm
you're disrupting them turn the ball
over you guys seem pretty confident and
comfortable in the offensive end what's
keyed to both of those elements
honestly they just missed some shots
that's that's part of the game
um
I think our our game plan is kind of
simple in the fourth quarter if I'm
being brutally honest it's kind of like
uh giving the ball to move and I gotta
I'm tasked with making the right play
sometimes you shoot the ball most of the
time and shoot the ball and a lot of
times it's passed the ball to the open
guy
um and I pride myself on finding that
open guy I really do I want to get all
my teammates involved and I've never
been a guy to say that the player that I
am today isn't because of my teammates
it's always because of them they always
make shots it makes my job so much
easier if I get beat on defense
somebody's always there I have so much
faith in this group of guys that we have
and I've said it all year long we're
going to ride with one another to the
will follow
do you feel like because of that you
have kind of a mental Edge on them at
this point
I don't think so I just think we're so
worried about us as a team us as a unit
that we don't it's not like we don't
focus on them because we do you know we
talk about everything that they do but
at the end of the day we have to be the
best version of ourselves we have to
believe in one another we got to go out
there and compete together
um withstand the runs that they will go
on and um be able to make runs of our
own and at the end of the day we can
always live with the result because we
did it together
Jimmy you talked through the years here
about the confidence everybody pours
into you and everybody pours in everyone
else why is the belief so strong within
that no matter what the situation is in
a game that you guys will find a way to
win
we we see it every day in practice on
off days guys are constantly working on
their game guys are constantly studying
film
um and guys just want to win
at the end of the day that's that's all
anybody wants on this roster
if you ask him to do something as long
as it's for winning they're going to do
it
um nobody on this roster is dumb so they
can tell whenever it's about winning and
whenever you're telling them something
because the end goal is winning and then
more than anything like I always say we
just man we end this thing together we
we love it that way and um we'll
continue to play that way and have fun
while we're doing it
Jimmy you guys finished seventh record
in the East number eight seed but
there's been that sort of will all along
do you expect this did you when that
Chicago game is over already yeah but
just when you when you reach a point
like this now at 2-0 in this series
maybe other people are talking about a
surprise in the series your thought on
that we don't care we never have we
never will
we know what we're capable of
um we gonna be in this thing to the end
together good bad and different we are
who we are we are where we are and we're
going to continue to fight together